do you see all the rubits no i mean i
saw parts of what coffeezilla was
talking about well let's let's describe
it for those who haven't
watched this video yet it's basically
they looked into rubette which is the
gambling site that we had talked about
crypto gambling we talked about it like
i don't know a month or so ago about how
much money
influencers are making from these sites
because you know they're getting paid
out like multiple millions of dollars a
month these influencers are making each
to promote the gambling site to their
fans because
they basically get a rake off of
everyone's bet
all their fans who signs up with who
sign up with their promo code they get a
little bit of each one of their bets so
they're making a [ __ ] ton of money right
mm-hmm is i don't know i think it's
important distinction again a reminder
that they get a percentage of what
people bet you have to remember that
adjusts so someone puts 5k in they get a
the same percent you know they get an
equivalent percentage of that versus
someone putting in 500 yes but the more
people are inclined to put in the more
they're making you know and they they
would fly them to cabo
be because it's like technically legal i
guess to play it there yeah and to
stream it there but like all the fans
that are signing up are using vpns and
they're doing it illegally so the whole
thing is like really sketchy because
it's all based in [ __ ] cacao or
whatever kakuas or something like that
some island where they they kind of give
out gambling licenses gaming licenses
sorry like liberally i just butchered
that but it's a whole whole ass country
and i just [ __ ]
some [ __ ] island anyways the whole
thing is like really just you know legal
gray area sketchy as [ __ ] this is
basically linking the guy who founded
that also founded whizza which is a site
that all the people that were on like
promoting this gambling site started
promoting and it's a giveaway website so
it's like you buy tickets
to join a lottery
and the more tickets you buy supposedly
increases your chance of winning the
grand prize which is a ferrari or
whatever the [ __ ] it's a classic
sweepstakes except if you look into the
fine print it's not so coffee looked
into like the fine print which is
actually it's not the fine print it just
says it right on the front page there
so like the website ui is set up where
it's like you buy five tickets you buy
10 tickets you buy 150 tickets or you
buy 200 tickets each for a different
price right yeah more tickets you buy
the cheaper it is
so like the way it's set up it's
inferred that the more tickets you buy
it raises your chance of winning right
because it puts your name in the bucket
multiple times but if you go down and
scroll it says
buying tickets buying more tickets does
not increase your chance of winning
which is so wild so it's like what the
[ __ ] is this website then yeah and i
think it's either a way to launder the
money they're making from reubet or it's
trying to get around the rules of being
a sweepstakes because there's super
strict rules of doing that otherwise
everyone would just [ __ ] start a
lottery and so by not by basically
making it like a charity instead by them
saying oh yeah buying doesn't do
anything you can enter for free if you
want it's it's like uh it's not actually
sweepstakes it's like people donating
instead of buying entry to a sweepstakes
yeah i think that's probably what it is
i'm not a [ __ ] lawyer but like that's
kind of what it seems like so anyways
like the whole thing is crazy and
sketchy and this might end up being like
one of the biggest
scams in the last
i mean
i don't know when's the last
influencer scam like this it's crazy i
mean csgo was like the big one then that
dude is
the dude allen or whatever i guess was
connected to that as well what what it
was that like skin that was like buying
skins and yeah they were like
basically they were
similar thing people were
um i think paying to
win
skins and then the lottery was rigged
and faze banks did that too right
what
like a cs go skin i don't know if he was
involved in that he might have been
another big one was like that kid t
martin or whatever but yeah i mean this
this whole operation is crazy i don't
know how many of these dudes fly to
another country and don't feel sketched
out by the fact that they had to go to
another country to you know i neither i
don't know it's like you're 20 whatever
they are
and you see
these big ass checks millions of dollars
every month right they're probably just
blinded by the fact that this is so much
money yeah they're like ah [ __ ] it we'll
take a chance and they don't realize
like the damage they're actually doing
in terms of getting kids
hooked
to a [ __ ] gambling website it's going
to ruin their life this is like this
could be an addiction they can't shake
in the future i don't know i think a
good lesson is just like if it looks too
good to be true it it is you know what
i'm saying i think this whole thing is
going to come crashing down because you
should not be able to go from zero to
buying mclaren's every single month yeah
you know what i'm saying that doesn't
happen
you're not saying it shouldn't happen
i'm just saying like it doesn't i don't
know i feel like anyone who makes money
through or that kind of money at least
through like legitimate ways like knows
what it takes to get there so they don't
yeah they don't throw it away yeah yeah
i think the the rate
that the money is shown up is it's it's
so obvious that someone's getting rinsed
you know like
that's the only way and and i guess you
could argue that they shouldn't have
that money because if all the people
using the websites didn't have you know
vpns and that sort of thing they just
wouldn't be able to access it yeah you
know that was like
like when full tilt and
those guys had those issues you know
back in the day when they basically got
caught
having offshore accounts to run the
website they just you know start
blocking connection and you had to be in
certain states to play that you had to
be in vegas
or wherever to play poker online and it
technically should be that way right
like you should only be able to do it
where it's legal but even then
you shouldn't be getting a rake off of
it pretty bold man
it's pretty bold i think the part that's
bad about it is you know crypto already
has a lot of issues
combating the stigma of hurting the
environment and
being so susceptible to scamming that
this i feel just adds another notch to
it and
who knows man i mean with the amount of
money that's moving it's big enough that
an sec or like a federal body would be
like well what the [ __ ] like no yeah and
that could shape how crypto laws can
shake out yeah you know obviously
there's a lot of money in crypto so
maybe it wouldn't be like some doomsday
scenario but i just don't think that
this bodes well for it you know it kind
of jeopardizes what the intention of
crypto is supposed to be i think what's
also really interesting is how coffee
and you know some ordinary keep digging
up like the wallets i know i was just
about to comment on that that's crazy
yeah how the wallets have zero activity
which wallets well he's just saying yeah
yeah you know a lot of these guys
they'll reveal their wallet on accident
on stream and then when they go look it
up and it's like oh
money was never deposited yeah so they
never funded their own wallet which
means that the gambling website is just
giving them some of their fake currency
to gamble with publicly in front of
their fans yeah so it's like oh i'm
winning big uh i just lost 50k it's not
real yeah they're acting like they did
yeah which is just a whole nother level
of [ __ ] up and another funny thing is
like they track the wallets you know to
the people like to the you know the main
wallet funding all of ruben or whatever
yeah and then they're sending phase
banks money and then he's buying crypto
punks with that money yeah yeah and he's
on twitter saying like oh there's
life-changing money and crypto punks and
it's like but yeah you're getting it for
free and i don't i don't know i don't
remember what the actual link between
phase banks so don't quote me on this
but i mean he was in the video it just
like was got confusing tracking all the
wallets and it's really interesting the
whole thing just feels like just icky
it's you know and and you don't know if
it'll stop or keep going but it seems
that nfts
went from this thing that was like oh
this is the future to a lot of people
figure out how to scam off of it and now
that's all it really is you know i i
have a hard time believing a lot of nfts
are
worth their salt because it it it's
really off-putting to me when an nft
gets announced and
somehow 40 celebrities have it already
yeah you've never heard of this [ __ ]
already and then when you look at the
people making it it's like oh they're
like this artist who created stuff for
these people or you know oh it's like
this like sort of
guy who's connected with these people
all right it always seems like there's
just this kind of like vague character
in the center of it all although
coinbase is um
like opening up a nft marketplace you
see that yeah uh no but i'm
was bound to happen yeah i mean that
should just that should be good for the
whole thing yeah i mean because coinbase
i feel is one of the platforms that you
can kind of trust yeah my issue with nft
is is the same thing like even if
coinbase is legitimate it's like the
people starting the nfts is i have a big
ass question mark on them yeah this this
whole thing it makes you wonder if any
of these dudes will get caught up for it
yeah it's cause it seems like they're a
lot of their fans don't really seem to
care yeah
and it's like what's actually illegal
here
something might be the whole thing just
feels shady but it's like we don't know
what's actually it's immoral and
unethical for sure but it's like might
not be illegal yeah yeah by definition
it may not yeah i don't know
you